la société all SIM spécialisée dans le
ciment le béton faite ces 100 ans et à
cette occasion les 80000 salariés du
groupe ont la possibilité de participer
à des projets humains solidaires
environnementaux on va en parler dans un
instant avec le chef de ce projet sur ce
plateauaravant un exemple concret
c'était cet après-midi au Menil Saint- à
l'éend des Noé où 40 des collaborateurs
de cette entreprise ont contribué à la
sauvegarde des espèces de l'ét les
salariés d' SIM apprennent à manier a
dans l'ét des Noé au sein du parc
naturel régional de la Haute Vallée de
Chevreuse 40 employés volontaires du
spécialiste de ciment faitent les 100
ans de leur entreprise en contribuant à
la sauvegarde de la centaine d'espèces
d'oiseaux peuplant ce havre naturel
cette participation à des projets
solidaires et environnementaux est un
cadeau d'anniversaire plutôt original
mais surtout une aide précieuse pour la
faune et la flore du bassin envahie par
le bois ce qu'on veut c'est leur rendre
une certaine fonctionnalité écologique
et plus
particulièrement retrouver un maximum de
de
d'herbage donc avec toute une
biodiversité flore et faune les insectes
en particulier les salariés d'sim
travaille un peu plus d'un hectare qui
sera ensuite remis en paturage avec des
poneys rustiques pour maintenir le
milieu dégagé c'est aussi l'occasion de
se côtoyer dans un autre univers où la
hiérarchie du bureau est vite oubliée il
y a des contrôleurs de gestion il y a
des des secrétaires des comptables des
directeurs enfin il y a un peu tout le
monde qui est représenté
aujourd'hui dans dans la nature donc on
est habillé différemment d'habitude et
c'est fort sympathique parce que là on
est vraiment tous à égalité voyez avec
le même le même uniforme on apprend à
manier la sisaille et peut-être même la
hiérarchie est complètement inversée des
fois l'entreprise continue ses bonnes
actions jusqu'au 16 novembre sur
d'autres sites du département 1 salariés
il participent dans toute la
France la société hsim a 100 ans et
c'est une société solidaire bonsoir
Christophe Pimpi Christian Pimpi pardon
vous êtes le chef de projet de ce projet
baptisé en ensemble est solidaire à
l'occasion des 100 ans vous donnez la
possibilité à vos salariés d'aller
donner du temps de travail parce que
c'est sur leur temps de travail que ça
fonctionne pour aller aider des
associations c'est bien ça l'idée c'est
exactement ça donc c'est à l'occasion du
centenaire du groupe SIM qui est un des
leaders mondiaux de la production de
ciment granula et béton
80000 salariés dans le monde et dans 70
pays et en France 1800 salariés donc à
le groupe sim a souhaité donner
l'opportunité à ses salariés de pouvoir
sortir de de leur quotidien et pouvoir
consacrer une journée de leur travail
sur des actions de solidarité donc
partout en France et ils sont comme all
au travail exactement ça repose sur le
bénévolat des euh des salariés mais
c'est pris sur leur temps de travail
donc ce n'est pas décomter sur leur leur
congé payé par
exemple depuis lundi ça du 12 au 16
exactement ça démarré hier jusqu'à sur
les 1800 avoir accepté de jouer le jeu
parce que c'était sur la base du du
volontariat
aussi exactement à l't temp de no par
exemple exactement donc on est très fier
d'avoir mobilisé plus de 50 % de nos
salariés c'est une belle réussite
d'utant plus que c'est une première à
cette cette échelle
et et donc c'est sur l'ensemble de ces
salariés on a déjà des échos qui sont
extrêmement positif on a beaucoup de
retours comme on a pu voir sur ce
reportage est-ce que le but c'est
d'apporter quoi déjà pour les salariés
pour l'entreprise c'est aussi de de
communiquer de montrer cette image et de
s'affirmer sur les questions
environnementales humaines mais mais
pour les salariés c'est c'est de de les
impliquer sur le leur travail d'aller à
la rencontre des autres voilà justement
le le groupe olsim engagé depuis de
nombreuses années dans une démarche
écoresponsable et l'objectif c'était de
prolonger cette action jusqu'au niveau
des salariés et et leur permettre de
s'intégrer totalement à cette démarche
donc pouvoir eux eux-mêmes qu'il
puissent participer être acteur de cet
engagement SIM au quotidien de le rendre
le plus concret possible on revoit les
images de l'action on a vu le reportage
tout à l'heure d'Antony rche et Elodie
Mo c'était auil saint sur les temps des
Noé quelles sont les les autres actions
ont été mené là il y avait une
quarantaine de collaborateurs qui qui
ont participé sur les 1000 en France il
y a des projets un peu partout il y en
avait du côté de manilamo au Jardin de
Cocagne par exemple sur ces jardins
jardins solidairire mais quelles autres
actions ont été menées alors l'objectif
c'était de pouvoir proposer au salariés
une la plus grande variété possible
d'actions donc c'est 57 actions en tout
qui vont avoir lieu sur cette semaine
sur trois thèmes différents
l'environnement comme l'action qu'on a
pu voir aujourd'hui le handicap et et le
l'aide sociale 48 associations qui ont
profité de bénéficier en tout cas de
cette opération les associations elles
ont été choisies par unicité c'est un
partenaire sur cette opération pour vous
oui c'est ça on s'est adossé à
l'association unicité qui est donc été
lancée en 1994 et qui a pour rôle de
promouvoir le service civique et donc de
par le fait de cette mission ils ont une
connaissance très fine du maillage
associatif en France ils ont aidé à
sélectionner les associations sur
lesquelles on pouvait vraiment se rendre
utile et
euh contribution ch chises associations
bien sûr on avait en fait tout la
l'organisation de ce projet est partie
est basée sur une décentralisation
complète on on a créé quatre comités
régionaux avec des directeurs
opérationnels et des Responsables
Ressources humaines qui ont pu choisir
avec une cité les actions pour pour
s'assurer qu'elle correspondrait au au
maximum aux attentes de nos de nos
salariés 1000 collaborateurs qui ont
participé en France sur les les 1800 le
travail a continué pour autant et va
continuer tout au long de la semaine
tout au long de l'opération
donc ça c'est un véritable défi c'était
tout en permettant nos salariés de
d'urer pour des associations de continu
à servir nos clients et tout en
préservant les conditions de sécurité
sur nos sites qui reste bien entendu un
un impératif pour nous ça va se
poursuivre vous allez renouveler cette
opération c'est trop lourd à organiser
donc une fois déjà c'est bien alors on
va déjà là c'est une première à ce
niveau comme je vous comme je vous le
disais donc on va déjà débriefer un
petit peu de cette des résultats mais
bon pour l'instant on est assez conf
confiant car tous les échos qu'on a sont
extrêmement positifs mais l'ambition est
au minimum de susciter
le le plus possible d'initiative d'envie
de la part de nos salariés pour soit
qu'il continuent eux à titre individuel
soit au niveau local sur l'ensemble de
nos sites que que l'initiative puisse
continuer perdurer dans le temps mais là
ce sera pas sur le temps de travail des
salariés s'il font ça en plus pourquoi
pas si c'est des partenairesqu pourquoi
pas voilà ça dépendra des retours que
vous avez tout au long de la semaine et
ces opérations qui sont menées ensemble
et solidaires Christian pimpille de la
société hsim merci d'être venue sur ce
plateau et donc la société qui s'occupe
de de desciiment notamment des bétons et
qui organise cette opération pour
permettre à ses salariés d'aller donner
de leur temps et aller aider comme
aujourd'hui à les temps des Noé merci à
vous une dernière information ce soir
une information politique pour parler
des dernières de la dernière ligne
droite dans l'élection à la présidence
de l'UMP les derniers meeting et des
deux candidats auront lieu dans les
Evelin l'élection est prévue ce dimanche
pour quelques 12000 militants du
département et des ce soir François
Fillon sera à poissie entouré de ses
soutiens locaux Gérard Larché sénateur
Valérie pécrez David Douillet les
députés Étienne pin aussi ancien député
ancien maire de Versailles et
Jean-François Copé de son côté sera lui
à Saint-Germain au samedi dans
l'après-midi la veille de l'élection
avec Henry Guenot ou encore
Jean-Frédéric Poisson des députés qui
eux ont choisi le camp de l'actuel
secrétaire général du parti et pour
l'instant c'est dans les derniers
sondages l'ancien Premier ministre qui
est donné vainqueur prochaine édition
mercredi 14 novembre culture au
programme les Hipop Games et puis le
salon histoire lire de Versailles nous
parlerons aussi de la Journée Mondiale
du Diabète excellente soirée sur
TVfil